26 قتيلا على الاقل وعشرات الجرحى في هذه
اصطدام قطارين في مدينه لاريسا باليونان
البنتاجون يقول ان ايران تحتاج ل 12 يوما
لانتاج قنبله نوويه والوكاله الذريه ترصد
جزيئات يورنيوم عاليه التخصيب
اوكرانيا تعلن التصدي لصاروخ الروسي
واسقاط خمس مسيرات في بولتوفا والمعارك
تحتدم حول بخموت
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فتره اخباريه جديده
من العربيه نبداها بهذه النشره قتل 26
شخصا واصيب العشرات بجروح وفق اخر حصيله
وذلك بعد صدام قطارين قرب مدينه لاريسا في
اليونان في وقت متاخر من ليل الثلاثاء اقل
حاكم منطقه سيليا اليوناني ان العربات
الاربعه الاولى من قطار الركاب خرجت عن
مسارها بينما دمرت اول عربه بالكامل
تقريبا
للوقوف على المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا
الحادث من اثينا ينضم الينا دكتور عبد
اللطيف درويش استاذ اقصاد واداره الازمات
بجامعه كارديف صباح الخير دكتور
هل من معلومات دكتور حول كيفيه وقوع هذا
التصادم خاصه ان المعلومات تشير ان احد
القطارات كان قطار للركاب والاخر لبضائع
الحقيقه يعني الغريب ان يكونوا على نفس
السكه يعني ليست بهذه الحوادث فهما كانوا
على نفس السكه وتم اصطدام القطارين يقدر
عدد الاشخاص في القطارين حوالي 350 شخص
الان الاحصائيات تقول عن 29 قتيل وخمسه
وثمانين جريح قد يرتفع العدد وخمسه وعشرين
من الجرحى ووضعهم خطير ايضا وصلت درجه
الحراره في العربات الاولى تقريبا نتيجه
انفجار هي المنطقه المطعم
وايضا الكافيتيريا وصلت الى درجه حراره
1200 او 1500 فكان يتعذر عليهم الاقتراب
من المنقذين الاقتراب من العربتين قبل
اطفائها نتيجه ارتفاع درجات الحراره انا
اعتقد واتمنى اكون مخطئ ان عدد القتل
سيزيد وتم اعتقال حاليا ويتم التحقيق معهم
مدير الشركه
مدير الشفت الليلي الذي يعني يتعين ان
يكون قادرين او هم المسؤولين عن عمليه
اداره مسيره القطارات
نعم دكتور بالتاكيد عمليات الانقاذ
المستمره في محيط الحادث ولكن هل من اي
معلومات عن سائقي القطارين هناك تعويض
دائما على التحقيق معهما لفهم ما حدث
اعتقد ان السائق القطار والفنيين وهم
الذين يفترض ان يكونوا بالعربات الاولى
اعتقد انهم لن يكونوا على قيد الحياه
لانهم ايضا الصدام ودرجه الحراره او
الحريق الذي تم تم في العربات الاولى
واعاده التكنيشن او الفنيين وسائق القطار
هم في العربات الاولى هذا للاسف ايضا هناك
عدد كبير من الطلبه لانه كان لدينا اجازه
قبل يوم تقريبا
دينيه في اليونان يوجد عدد كبير من الطلبه
على القطارين هذه لان ايضا هناك جامعات
بين المدن اليونانيه في كل مدن فيتم
الذهاب الى اسرهم للاسف ايضا سيكون هناك
عدد من الشباب الصغار او يعني عين على
القطار اعتقد لن يكون على قيد الحياه لا
السائق ولا الفنيين اتمنى هل هناك معلومات
حول ارقام للناجين نعلم ان الرقم ارتفع
فيما يتعلق بالضحايا الى قتيلا حتى اللحظه
كما ذكرت ولكن هل هناك ايه ارقام عن
الناجين
حتى الان
عمليه الانقاذ تجري لانه ايضا وصلت
قوات من الانقاذ
ولا يزال ايضا بعمليه انتشال افراد وايضا
يجب عمليه ايضا الوصول الى بعض العربات
لانها ايضا منطقه والساعه التي حدثت فيها
الحادث هي ساعه ليليه وحتى الان تجري
عمليه القرض ليست هناك ارقام دقيقه حتى عن
الناجين حتى اللحظه ولكن العديد من الركاب
بادروا بنفسهم في فتره لحظه وقوع الحادث
بتكسر الزجاج العربات والخروج منها ولكن
حتى الان لا يوجد يعني ارقام عن عدد النجم
شكرا لك الدكتور على كل هذه المعلومات
دكتور عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ الاقتصاد
واداره الازمات بجامعه كارديف تحياتي
دكتور
كشفت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه عن
اكتشاف جزيئات يورنيوم وخاصه في ايران تقل
نقاوتها عن تسعين بالمئه وهي نسبه كافيه
لصنع سلاح النووي وقلت الوكاله ان ايران
ارجعت هذه النسبه الى امكانيه حدوث خلل في
عمليه التخصيب الا ان الوكاله انتقدت
ايران لعدم شفافيه في السماح بمراقبه
منشاتها النوويه وكانت الطاقه الذريه اكدت
ايضا ان مخزون ايران من اليورينيوم المخصب
بنسب مختلفه زاد بنحو 87 كيلو جرام منذ
اخر تقرير فصلي ليصل الى اكثر من 3000
وافادت الوكاله ان هذا المخزون يتجاوز
السقف المسموح به لايران باكثر من ثماني
عشره مره كما اضافت الوكاله ان ايران
لديها 42 كلغ من اليورينيوم المخصب
بالنسبه 60% وهو يحتاج لتعزيز بسيط لانتاج
سلاح النووي
من جهته قال البينتاجون ان ايران كانت
تحتاج الى 12 شهرا لانتاج قنبله نوويه في
عام 2018 والان تحتاج الى 12 يوما وخلال
جلسه استماع في مجلس النواب اكد وكيل
وزاره الدفاع لشؤون السياسات دكتور
اكد ان طهران تحقق تقدما لافتا في
برنامجها النووي منذ انسحاب اداره ترامب
من الاتفاق النووي عام 2015
كانت تقدم النووي الايراني منذ خروجنا من
الاتفاق النووي لافتا بالعوده الى عام
2018 عندما قررت الاداره السابقه لانسحاب
من الاتفاق النووي كان من الممكن ان
تستغرق ايران حوالي 12 شهرا لانتاج قنبله
نوويه واحده من المواد الانشطاريه الان
سيستغرق الامر حوالي 12 يوما اعتقد انه من
غير المرجح ان يمارس الروس ضغوطا على
ايران للانضمام الى اي اتفاق دبلوماسي
لانهم يحاولون دفع ايران لشحن المزيد من
الطائرات بدون طيار والصواريخ وغيرها من
القدرات
الجمهوريه وعضوي لجنه العلاقات الدوليه في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه كروز بيانا قال فيه
ان الرسو السفن الحربيه الايرانيه في
البرازيل يعد تطورا خطيرا وتهديدا مباشرا
لسلامه وامن الامريكيين كما اكد في البيان
على ان لدى الولايات المتحده قوانين
لمكافحه الارهاب مصممه لردع تهديدات والرد
عليها
في مقابلته الخاصه مع العربيه يتحدث رئيس
الوزراء الاوكرانيين دينيشي ميهال عن ملف
محاربه الفساد في بلاده المسؤول الاوكراني
كشف انه خلال الشهر المقبل سيتم تعيين
رئيس لمكتب مكافحه الفساد لمتابعه هذه
القضايا
اربعه اجهزه حكوميه في اوكرانيا الشرطه
والمخابرات ومكتب مكافحه الفساد ومحكمه
مكافحه الفساد وخلال شهر مارس سيتم
التعيين رئيس مكتب مكافحه الفساد في
اوكرانيا تكمل الاجهزه المعنيه التحقيقات
في ملفات عده وانا مقتنع بانه حتى النصف
الاول من شهر مارس ستكون الحكومه وعينت
رئيس المكتب الوطني
لمكافحه الفساد
واتهم شنيهاال الغزوه الروسيه لبلاده
بالتسبب في ازمه غذاء عالميه
شكرا يا واحده من اكبر مصدري المنتجات
الغذائيه خاصه حبوب الذره وللاسف ادى
الحصار الذي فرضه الروس على الموانئ
البحريه الاوكرانيه الى واحده من اكبر
الزامات الغذاء وهي ازمه الغذاء التي يمكن
ان تكون لها اثار ماساويه حقا في العديد
من البلدان الافريقيه والعديد من دول
الشرق الاوسط
لحسن الحظ تمكنا من تنظيم ممرات لوجستيه
عبر اوروبا وايضا عبر موانئ الدانوب وايضا
تنظيم ممر حبوب بشكل عام خلال هذا العام
من الحرب صدرت اوكرانيا نحو 50 مليون طن
من منتجات الحبوب الغذائيه منها 21 مليون
طن عبر البحر الاسود رغم الحصار وصل الروس
اغلاق جزء كبير من موانئنا فقد ثلاثه
موانئ كانت تعمل لتصدير الحبوب فقط ثلاث
سفن في اليوم سمح لها الروس بالعبور عبر
نقاط المتفق عليها في تركيا واستطعنا
تصدير حوالي 50 مليون طن اذا استقر الوضع
في سوق المواد الغذائيه بالطبع الان في
شهر مارس ستكون المرحله المقبله تنتهي
بالماء البارد ونطلب من جميع الشركاء خلق
ضغط مناسب على روسيا من اجل الاستمرار في
ممر الحبوب حتى لا يتسبب في المستقبل
بازمه الحبوب والغذاء
المقابله الكامله مع رئيس الوزراء
اوكرانيا دينيسيوم اجرتها زميلها ليان
الاختيار وتحدثت نهال عن دعم دول الخليج
الانساني والاقتصاديه لاوكرانيا كما تحدث
عن العقوبات الجديده التي تقترحها بلاده
على روسيا وستتابعون المقابله كامله اليوم
في الرابعه عصرا بتوقيت جرينتش اسابيع
بتوقيت السعوديه
ميدانيا اعلنت اوكرانيا التصدي دفاعاتها
الجويه لصاروخ روسي في بولتوفا واسقاط خمس
مسيرات في المدينه الواقعه شمال شرق
البلاد في غضون ذلك اكد رئيس الاوكراني ان
المعارك لا تزال تحتدم في محيط بخموت التي
تسعى روسيا لاسقاطها
هنا في بخمه الاوكرانيه تقترب اطول واشرس
معركه في الحرب من نهايتها حيث تقول
المعلومات والصور القادمه من هناك ان
الخناق يضيق على المقاومين الاوكران ضيق
يقابله اصرار على الصمود حتى النهايه
المدينه الصغيره بحجمها الكبيره في اسمها
وموقعها الاستراتيجي اصبحت ايقونه في
الحرب الدائره منذ عام ورمزيه للانتصار
لمن يسيطر عليها بعد اشهر من الجمود على
طول الجبهات المشتعله شرقا وجنوبا
تعتبر بخموت اخر القلاع الاوكرانيه في
اقليم دونيتسك شرقي اوكرانيا وهدفا رئيسيا
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حيث سيمنح
الاستيلاء عليها موسكو انتصارا نادرا بعد
عده اشهر من النكسات موقع المدينه يشكل
نقطه التقاء استراتيجيه بين منطقتي
تشكلان القلب الصناعي الاوكراني اضافه
لكونها تعتبر نقطه انطلاق جديده للجيش
الروسي باتجاه العمق الاوكراني واكبر
مدينتين في المنطقه هما
اكرامز تقول اخر المعلومات ان قوات فاجنر
دخلت احياء باخموت الشرقيه والوسطى فيما
تزال الاحياء الشماليه بيد الجيش
الاوكراني لتتحول المعركه الى حرب شوارع
بين الطرفين
لم تنفي صعوبه الوضع في المدينه شبه
المحاصره لكنها تصر وجيشها على الصمود رغم
شراسه المعارك وموقفها المعقد
يمكن لجميع ان يرى اننا نواجه صعوبه في
هذا القسم الامامي العدو يهاجم باستمرار
في مجموعه صغيره وكبيره فاحيانا يواصلون
القصف المدفعي واليوم التالي يشنون هجمات
المشاه انه امر صعب لكن اولادنا يستمرون
في الصمود بارضهم
بين ترقب سقوط وقدره على الصمود فالاكيد
ان القتال في باخمت اصبح معركه كسر عظم
بين الطرفين معركه قد تكون انعطافه جديده
لحرب بدات لتوها عامها الثاني
مسؤولون التنفيذيون في شركه ان مصنع لوكيد
مارت المحمول لقاذفات الصواريخ في اركنسس
يستعد لتعزيز انتاج نظام هاي مارس بعد ان
حقق نجاحا في معارك اوكرانيا وزياده الطلب
عليه من الدول الاخرى وحسب مسؤول الشركه
فانه بفضل بعض الاستثمارات التي تم
اجرائها خلال العام الماضي لم تعد الشركه
بحاجه الى لبعض تحسينات لتلبيه معدل
الانتاج المتزايد
قالت المخابرات الايطاليه ان روسيا بحاجه
لوقفه عمليه للاستعداد لحرب طويله واضافت
المخابرات الايطاليه ان روسيا تستغل
الركود الحالي لتسريع نشاط الصناعات
العسكريه التي تاثرت بالعقوبات الغربيه
اعتبرت المخابرات الايطاليه انه من غير
المرجح ان تستخدم روسيا الاسلحه النوويه
ونبقى معكم في سياق النشاط الصباح من
العربيه ولدينا
مشروعا لتاسيس اول فرقه موسيقيه نسائيه في
اليمن ضمن مبادره الفن مهنتي
نواصل مع حضراتكم تقديم نشره الصباح من
العربيه في مقابله خاصه للعربيه اشار
مستشار المبعوث الامامي الى سوريا ذاتيلي
نعوميك اشار الى انه لم يتهم احد روسيا
باعاقه عمليه وصول المساعدات الى المناطق
الشماليه في سوريا
انا كنت موجودا خلال المحادثات بين وزير
الخارجيه
الامومي الخاص الى سوريا جير بيترسون ولا
اذكر انه قال مثل هذا الشيء بان روسيا
تعيق عمليه دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى
الشمال السوري تم بحث نقاط العبور وكيفيه
تامين المساعدات متى واين ولكن مثل هذه
المعلومات هي مغلوطه لكن لم يتهم احد
روسيا بانها تعيق عمليه وصول المساعدات
قال نائب الاواني مندوب روسيا في مجلس
الامن ديميسي بولينيسكي ان عددا من الوفود
في مجلس الامن تتغاضى عن افعال من وصفهم
بالارهابيين في شمال غرب سوريا الذين
يمنعون دخول المساعدات وان بعض الاعضاء
يحاولون توجيه اللوم الى روسيا بولينسكي
قال ايضا ان روسيا تعتبر استمرار اسرائيل
في الاستفزازات المسلحه ضد سوريا امر غير
مقبول
اكد المبعوث الاممي الى سوريا ان
الاستجابه الفعاله لكارثه الزلزال تاثرت
بفعل النزاع لافتا ان الوضع الحالي اصبح
غير مقبول اطلاقا
والواقع الاليم هو ان الاستجابه الفعاله
قد تعرقلت بسبب تحديات المرتبطه بالمسائل
عالقه وهي في صلب النزاع لطالما كررت ان
الحاله في سوريا غير مستدامه وان الوضع
الحالي غير مقبول وان السوريين عرضه
لمسائل لا يتحكمون بها نفسهم
قال رئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف رشيد ان
بلاده تدعم عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه جاء ذلك خلال لقائه مع وزير
الدوله البريطاني لشؤون الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا طارق احمد واكد رشيد ان
بغداد تتمتع بعلاقات جيده وبناءها مع دول
الجوار
حاولت شبكه سي ام بي سي اللجوء الى شات جي
بي تي لتنظيم رحله سفر وجاءت نتيجه انه لا
يمكن التعويض بشكل كامل على الاجوبه التي
يعطيها تطبيق هذا فضلا عن اعترافه بانه
تطبيق ذكاء اصطناعي وليس لديه تفضيلات
شخصيه كي يوصي بها ويقدمها دون غيرها
روبوت دردشه الذكاء الاصطناعي او كما يسمى
تشات جي بي تي يكتب النثر والشعر والنصوص
البرمجيه باختصار انه يبدو كانسان يعترف
حتى باخطائه شبكه سي ان بي سي جربت
التطبيق على طريقتها لاختبار مدى دقه
المعلومات التي يقدمها حيث حاولت طلب
تنظيم رحله سفر فرد عليها بانها فكره
رائعه ثم رشح لها عده دول بناء على
تفضيلاتها لكن في ختام المحادثه خلصت
تقرير الى انه لا يمكن التعويل بشكل كامل
على الاجوبه التي يعطيها التطبيق فالخطا
الفادح وقع حينما قدم توصيه بفندق
على انه في بالي لكنه في الحقيقه يقع في
كندا
اما تذاكر السفر فلا يمكن لتطبيق الذكاء
الاصطناعي تقديم معلومات عن الرحلات
الحاليه او المساعده في حجزها او تحديد
اسعارها فقط يقدم اسماء شركات الطيران
وحتى حينما سئل الروبوت عن رايه في افضل
شركه طيران اكتفى بالاجابه انه ليس لديه
تفضيلات او اراء شخصيه وفوق ذلك اشار الى
افضل خمس شركات طيران حسب سكاي تراكس خلال
العام 20 21 الا ان القائمه وفق سي ان بي
سي تعود للعام 2019
وبشكل او باخر فان الروبوت قد وقع هذه
المره في حفرته فبعد ان حاول ان يهدد
العالم بالرموز النوويه وبهندسه وباء يفتك
بالعالم وانه يحلم بان يصبح انسانا ها هو
بحروفه يؤكد انه مجرد تطبيق ذكاء اصطناعي
مشروع جديد لتاسيس اول فرقه موسيقيه
نسائيه متخصصه في عدن اطلقت المبادره ضمن
مشروع الفن مهنتي التي تنظمها مؤسسه عدن
للفنون والعلوم بهدف تدريب النساء في مجال
الاداره الثقافيه والعزف على الالات
الموسيقيه نتابع
باصرار تقضي هؤلاء الفتيات العشر ساعات في
عزف انواع الموسيقى بالعديد من الاتها
استعدادا للاعلان عن مشروع هو الاول من
نوعه في البلاد اول فرقه الموسيقيه
النسائيه متخصصه
ثم من هذا المشروع خصيصا للنساء والفتيات
لندره وجود النساء في الوسط الفني يهدف
المشروع الى تشكيل فرقه موسيقيه نسائيه
وهذه تعتبر الفرقه الاول في عدن واليمن
وسيكون مخرج التدريب طبعا التنظيم لاول
حفل موسيقي نسائي امام
الجمهورات تعلمت على اله الجيتار يمكن
حوالي لنا ثلاثه اسابيع او اربع اسابيع
لليوم استفدت كثير يعني كنت ما عنديش اي
خلفيه في الجيتار ولا كنت اعرف اعزف حاجه
فعلمون احنا كثير يعني عادوا باقي شويه
بنوصل لمستوى ارقى يعني واحسن
مبادره ضمن مشروع الفن مهنتي الذي يهدف
لتدريب النساء في مجالات الثقافه
والموسيقى
ويهدف المشروع ايضا لاعاده القطاع النسائي
الى خوض غمار مجالات انقطعت عنها لفتره
طويله في مدينه عدن التي كانت رائده في
الفن والموسيقى اجت هنا على المعهد ده
علشان يعني اقدر يعني اطور في الموسيقى
وطبعا الموسيقى طبعا هي غذاء الروح طبعا
انا اخترت الاورج لانه الاورج يعني
بالنسبه لي اسهل لي
وكان يعني اعتمد على الاصوات هوايتي من
زمان اني ادرس العود يعني في شغف
وبدات اخترت اله العود لانه من التراث
التراث الشعبي
لما دقيت لهذه الدوره كنت طبعا صفر ولا
فاهمه اي حاجه في استفدت كثير الى الان
يعني بدات احفظ الاوتار واليت اتعلم
العزفك
[موسيقى]
واش
ته تتسم هذه التجربه بالكثير من الاصرار
والتحدي خصوصا من قبل الفتيات وهي تجربه
تعكس ايضا استعاده مدينه عدن لرونقها
الجميل رغم الظروف الحرب المستمره في
البلاد عندي فضول اتجاه اله الكمان بانه
هي اله صعبه ومش اي حد ممكن يتعامل
تدريب البنات هذه في مباراه تساعد في هذا
جابوا مئه بنت واختاروا منهم عشر انا
هذولا بتولى رعايتهم انا
باساتذه حقيقيين
رغم كل شيء تصر هذه الثله من الفتيات على
خوض غمار التحدي في مجال الموسيقى
ليفتحن بابا جديدا في عدن المدينه التي
تستعد رونقها متحديه هي الاخرى كل الظروف
العربيه
كل التحيه للنساء اليمن ختام هذه النشره
مع ابرز عناوينها
سته وعشرون قتيلا على الاقل وعشرات الجرحى
في حادث اصطدام قطارين في مدينه لاريسا
باليونان
البنتاجون يقول نيران تحتاج الى 12 يوما
لانتاج قنبله نوويه والوكاله الذريه ترصد
جزيئات يورينيو عاليه التخصيب
اوكرانيا تعلن التصدي لصاروخ الروسي
واسقاط خمس مسيرات في بولتوفا والمعارك
تحتدم حول فخمه
نلتقي بعد قليل في نشاط الاخباريه جديده
على العربيه ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]